good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs are
going to solve all of the world's major
problems so to help you on your journey
today's messages don't focus on the
money over to you Bob Marley you might a
lot of money out of your music morning I
mean what does almost almost as a lotta
money to you that's a good question have
you made say millions of dollars no are
you a rich man
William enrichment give me you have a
lot of possessions a lot of money in the
bank focus on making rich I know I don't
have that type of riches my riches is
life sorry if you just focus on the
money you're never going to get it this
is what so many entrepreneurs do and why
so many entrepreneurs fail is their
number one goal is money
now money is important if you're running
a business money is important you know
even if you're running the charity money
is so important money is important it's
just not the number one thing it's
number 2 or 3 there has to be something
more important than money for you to
have success ultimate success as an
entrepreneur sure you can make a few
bucks but if you look at the people
where the top in any field money was
never the number one goal now in this
clip Bob Marley's talking about how he's
not rich financially but he's rich in
life I'm saying you can be rich
financially and you can be rich in life
by not focusing on the money look at the
people who are self-made millionaires
and billionaires and read their
biographies and read their story and
understand why they started their
company watch the top ten videos on all
of them it's never been about the money
it's always been about making a profound
change the way something is done in
their industry having a deep passion for
their craft that they needed to bring
this thing out into creation
you know when George Lucas created Star
Wars he thought it would be a flop he
thought it would only be for select few
geeks who really loved that genre he
never expected it to be this huge thing
that turned him into a billionaire but
he loved making immediate when he poured
every ounce of sweet tea we had into
making that movie and that's a story
over and over and over and over and over
again successful entrepreneurs love
their craft they want to do the work and
as a result of creating something
valuable because they put so much love
into it then they start making money and
so I don't want you to be the
entrepreneur who says I don't care about
money money is never important to me
because then you don't go out and get
money and then you can't have the impact
like you need money to go out and hire
more people and have an even bigger
impact there's only so much you can do
it's great to spend half your time
working and happy time volunteering and
giving back it's awesome but you can
have a bigger impact and
here more if you had a team of a hundred
people who are also spreading out their
time volunteering so money is important
the people would think money is money is
the devil and you shouldn't have money
you're never going to be successful
either money is important it's just not
the number one thing don't start a
business just trying to make money start
a business to have a profound impact on
the way things are done in an industry
and help people that thing has to be
above for me it's helping entrepreneurs
I believe that entrepreneurs all've all
the major problems in the world it's not
on it's not on the government it's not
on corporations it's on us we're going
to make the difference and so for me
making these videos and helping by
writing books and doing the thing that I
do I feel helps entrepreneurs and help
contribute to solving all the major
problems of the world you guys out there
are going to be the ones who are making
a difference if I can motivate you or if
I can give you strategies to help you if
I help you keep on that extra year not
so year that makes a difference that
makes you feel good it makes me feel
like I'm having an impact that's why I
do what I do and in the process I make
money if I wasn't making money I
couldn't hire teamm and they'll be doing
everything myself and be down to one
video every two weeks which isn't good
for anybody the money is never the
number one goal but it's also not the
number 104 you've got to be two or three
on the list so the question of the day
today is I'm curious what is the number
one thing on your list that you would
put ahead of making money leaving the
comments below
really curious to find it I also want to
give a quick shout out to Mike Markham
from restaurant - HR comm Mike thank you
so much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word and making a review on it
I'm really glad you enjoyed it and I
really want to thank you for your
support so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot event spread
for this recipe we go
my family was never about my experiences
people do things for funny you make a
choice by which my love and then you'll
learn how to make money doing what you
love here less when I changed careers
I was never changing to something
through money I was changing us up in
our love
right and that to me that's really the
only way is up to keep passion if you
have two choices do the one is I in a
piano and another one I was out here
though bowling and we can make more
money pooling which love playing the
piano for you got to play a piano it's
like you'll tear yourself apart if
you're not good with the thing that's
love
in life and you know what it is right
now right now there's nothing that you
love more than everything whatever it is
it's love crazy has to be the thing that
you dedicate your life you make more
money than any actor in the world this
too shall pass
I by the way I don't even know if that's
true I can tell you I pay more taxes
than I've ever met
truth be told I've never ever been
motivated by money I gotta give it to
you man because you just seem like such
a normal guy how are you able to that is
my ground power talk exactly that's what
it is
people believe you're normal yeah
absolutely when you start outlet you
have to deal with the problems of
failure you need to be thick-skinned to
learn that not every project will
survive a freelance life a life in the
arts is sometimes like putting messages
in bottles on a desert island and hoping
that someone will find one of your
bottles and open it and read it and put
something in a bottle that will wash its
way back to you appreciation or a
commission or money or love and you have
to accept that you may put out hundreds
of things for every bottle that winds up
coming back the problems of failure the
problems of discouragement of
hopelessness of hunger you want
everything that happen and you want it
now and things go wrong my first book a
piece of journalism I done only for the
money and which had already bought me an
electric typewriter from the advance
should have been a best-seller it should
have paid me a lot of money if the
publisher hadn't gone into involuntary
liquidation between the first print run
selling out and the second print run
never happening and before any Broyles
is could be paid it would have done and
I shrugged and I still had my electric
typewriter and enough money to pay the
rent for a couple of months and I
decided that I'd do my best in future
not to write books just for the money if
you didn't get the money then you didn't
have anything and if I did work I was
proud of and I didn't get the money at
least I'd have the work every now and
then I forget that rule and whenever I
do
the universe kicks me hard
and reminds me I don't know that it's an
issue for anybody but me but it's true
that nothing I did we're the only reason
for doing it was the money was ever
worth it
except this bitter experience usually I
didn't wind up getting the money either
the things I did because I was excited
and wanted to see them exist in reality
have never let me down and I've never
regretted the time I spent on any of
them